-You look good, bud.
You look good.
-Thank you, sir.
-Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Thanks for being here.
How does it feel to be on
one of the biggest shows,
I mean, ever?
Right now, that's -- it's --
"Yellowstone," is --
it's beyond anything.
It's unbelievable.
-How does it feel?
Pretty damn good.
-Yeah, it does, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
-How does it feel?
-Last season premiere had over
14 million viewers, by the way.
-Not too shabby.
-No, it's not shabby at all.
-Yeah.
-And everyone's a fan
of the show.
And I was talking
to you backstage and I said,
"Is there any fans you were
like, 'Oh, I didn't know
they would be a fan.'"
But you were like,
"Well, Drake is a giant fan."
And I was like, "Is that right?"
-Yeah, that's a bit strange.
I didn't see that one coming.
-No.
-No, a buddy of mine, Jake,
said Drake, you know,
wants a pair of boots
for his birthday,
and I was like,
"He actually rides?"
Like,
"What are you talking about?"
And he's like,
"No, no, he doesn't ride.
He just wants a pair of boots,
and he wants you to ride
in the boots
and give them to him."
And I was like, "Fair enough."
[ Laughter ]
-That's what Drake does.
-Yeah, I mean, you know.
-And you actually did it.
Here you go.
-Yeah.
-You sent him a pair of boots.
There you go.
"Happy birthday!
Rip."
There you go.
You're a man of your word.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I might call on you, Drake.
-Yeah.
-I might call on you.
-Drake's actually a good actor.
Do you know -- maybe --
-I'm not aware of that.
-He is, yeah.
"Degrassi" is where he
kind of got his start.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
I'm just saying if there's room
for a cameo,
would you be down for that?
-Hell yeah.
-A Drake cameo?
-Bring it.
-Yeah, let's do it.
Drake in "Yellowstone"?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're great as Rip Wheeler.
Was it --
Was there any other character
or anything you went in
to read for,
you're like, "Oh, I think
I should do this one,"
or are you like,
"No, this is my character"?
-You know what?
I looked at the Dutton,
you know, family, and, to me,
I thought they were all great.
Obviously, you know,
Wes is phenomenal and Luke.
But what resonated to me
was Rip.
And, you know,
he has a darkness that I love
and a passion with Beth.
And I just thought, you know,
this is a character
that not only can grow, but
there's tons of colors in him.
So -- and as an actor, that's
kind of what you dream of, so...
-Yeah.
I mean, did you know
that your character would be --
become a heartthrob?
-No, Jimmy.
-Yeah.
-I didn't know that.
-Yeah, you're kind of --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a bit of a shocker.
-That's --
That's kind of fun.
People are dressing up
as you for Halloween.
I'm sure you saw that.
-I saw that in New York,
actually, the other day.
There was a guy
walking down the street.
I rolled down the window,
I go, "Rip!"
And he turned, he goes, "Yeah!"
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Not bad.
-I was like, "Okay.
He doesn't even know it's me."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
If you heard someone drive past
you and yell, "Rip"...
-Yeah.
-Yeah, and you said, "yeah,"
that was actually Rip.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that was --
[ Laughter ]
Actually, Chris Pratt
dressed up as Rip Wheeler.
-Who is that?
-Yeah.
You ever heard of this guy?
-Oh, my God.
Hold on a second.
[ Laughter ]
Looking good, kid.
-Yeah, he is looking good.
Looking good there, guy.
-Well done.
-Yeah.
-Look at -- Look at this.
This is how you grow a beard,
ladies and gentlemen.
That's the real deal.
-He's doing all right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're doing all right.
You're a little patchy here.
We could probably
stipple in a little bit,
maybe paint it in a little bit.
-Yeah, you can't even
look at these sides here.
-Don't worry.
I've got someone in the back.
He'll take care of you.
-Something to fill it in here.
Next time you come on, I'm gonna
have a full-on fake beard.
-Let it go, babe.
-Really?
-It's Christmas.
It's the holiday season.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you think I'm --
maybe I'm -- am I Santa?
[ Laughter ]
-Babe, you can be
whatever you want.
-Yeah, exactly.
Do you groom your stuff?
Do you, like, comb it and --
-No, I let it go.
-Do people -- I found that
people started giving me stuff,
like combs and oils.
-No, no, no.
Don't do it.
[ Laughter ]
-Try to be a man
and just let it go.
-What do you mean?
-It's okay.
-I think you oil it down.
-Mm.
-Maybe the ladies like it.
I don't know.
-Whoo!
[ Scattered cheers ]
-Is yours soft?
Does your wife like it?
-Yeah, touch it.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh, yours is very soft.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wow.
-Very sexual.
-Wow.
[ Both laugh ]
Let's write that into a scene
in "Yellowstone."
That's perfect.
I like that.
Oh, that was nice.
You're very soft.
-"That was nice."
[ Laughter ]
What are we doing?
-"What are we doing?" yeah.
Whoever thought we'd touch
each other's beards?
-In front of a bunch of people.
-Yeah, millions of people.
-Yeah, I love that.
-Yeah, exactly.
Can we say what's going on in
season five in "Yellowstone"?
-Sure.
-Yeah.
What is --
-What is going on?
-That was --
I meant that as a question.
-Fair enough.
-Yeah.
-Well, this year,
there's more Beth and I,
which I hope everybody
is excited about.
-Of course.
-We're married now,
which is gonna be interesting.
-Yeah.
-A lot more kind of
responsibility on Rip,
you know, obviously,
with John being the governor.
So more responsibility
as far as the ranch is concerned
and being the foreman
and running the ranch.
And, you know,
Taylor did a phenomenal job,
again, writing this year.
-Yeah.
I don't remember your
background, but are you from --
Do you know how to ride a horse?
And...
-Born in Laurel Springs
on a ranch.
-Oh, you did, yeah.
-And then Oregon, Florida,
back to California.
-No way.
-And now Montana
and back to Florida.
-Wow!
-So, yeah.
-Full circle.
-Yep.
-Yeah.
Show 'em how it's done.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Cole Hauser
in the season five premiere
of "Yellowstone."
Take a look at this.
-And when this gets going
and this gets going, too --
-But I robbed us
of so much time together,
because I was...
It's still robbing us.
-Mm.
Whatever it took, I don't need.
I'm happy, Beth.
With you, with life.
Everything's good.
-But we needed what I took.
-Listen, come here.
Come here.
Oh, baby.
[ Sighs ]
You need to find
somebody new to fight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Cole Hauser, everybody.
Season five of "Yellowstone"
premieres November 13th
at 8:00 p.m.
on Paramount network.